- On this episode, the
legend Fat Joe stops by.
- [Gary] The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 218 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
And if you're a Jersey boy, east
coast if you love music you're
as happy as I am right now
because I have a legend with me
Fat Joe, my man.
- Sup my brother?
- Why don't you tell the Vayner
Nation for the one person who's
watching this in who knows where
in the world that doesn't know
who you are, why don't you spend
a minute to say hello to
the Vayner Nation.
- How's it going my brothers?
My name is Fat Joe originally
from the Bronx, New York
reside in Miami for
the last 14 years.
- [Gary] The weather?
- Amazing in Miami.
Originally a member of the
Diggin' In The Crates crew
that's Lord Finesse, Showbiz,
happy birthday Lord Finesse.
Showbiz and A.G.,
Diamond D, O.C.,
Big L rest in peace.
Then the leading founder and
president of Terror Squad rest
in peace Big Pun, Remy Ma,
DJ Khaled the list goes on and on,
and whatever, Fat Joe.
- Listen, I'm sure everybody
knows and if they don't
that's their mistake.
Tell me what's on
your mind these days?
A lot of people that
are watching right now
entrepreneurs, marketers and
business people, the kind of
people you would enjoy.
I was born in Russia came up
baseball cards, lemonade stand,
a lot of people watch this
hustling, making this happen.
What's going on in
your business world?
What are you excited about?
Obviously Khaled had this
phenomenal situation in the last
year with Snapchat.
Obviously you've
been out and about.
- Well, you know I am president
of urban and Latino division a
company called
MarketAmericaShop.com.
- Yep.
- We teach people how to be
entrepreneurs and teach them the
importance of residual income.
- Yes.
- Working one time in your
life and always getting
paid for it forever.
So I work with my Latinos and
my Black people in this business
but the business has been around
for 24 years and and Asians and
white people you know have
made the three and half billion
dollars doing this
business right here.
So I'm teaching the Latinos and
the Black people how to do this.
We sell vitamins, we sell make
up, all those cosmetics so I've
been doing that for the last
two years as well as I've always
been doing my music.
- Always.
- My main hustle is my music.
I've been doing
that since day one.
- When did music hit your life?
Literally out the womb?
When you are three?
- Well I loved
music since day one.
But growing up in the Bronx
emulating my brother
you know what I'm saying looking
outside my window is pretty much
where hip hop music was created.
- Of course.
- We had what we used to
call jams, block parties right
outside my window.
So me being four or five years
old I used to see them come
outside, bring the turntables
and we used to go out there and
listen to the music and then
I just fell in love with
hip hop, breakdancing and
graffiti.
I got into so much trouble
writing graffiti on trains.
I got thrown out of maybe
six, seven junior high schools
writing graffitis.
And then I got into rapping
and battle rapping everybody.
I always say I was the original
Eminem 'cause I used to battle a
whole bunch of Black kids but
I had a blonde hair and
green eyes and I was
kicking that gangster shit.
And they was looking out like
I was fucking crazy every time.
- Yep. You got a reputation.
- Here we are.
- Yep.
So actually my own, now I'm
being selfish, I'm sorry,
I'm just taking full advantage.
What's your point of view on
the current state of hip hop?
What are you seeing out there
what are your thoughts on some
of the people that are coming up?
What people listen to?
- I love J Cole.
- Yep.
- I'm a huge J Cole fan.
I love his
freedom of expression.
Pusha T's my favorite album.
I love Kanye West's new album.
I love music, man, and
everything is gotta evolve.
- That's right.
- You know what I'm saying?
I love our era that I
came out of in the 90s.
- Yep.
- I also think the era before
ours, the LL Cool J,
Public Enemy, Heavy D,
KRS One was better than ours.
- Sure.
You grew up with it, right?
- Yeah, I grew up with it.
- You feel like a lot of the
legends, the people have been
through it like yourself,
sometimes too often are quick to
downplay seven years ago the
South or new guys that come up?
Do you feel like
there's too much of that?
Like, people are trying to
push against it because
it's not theirs?
- Yeah, I believe,
I believe it needs to evolve.
- That's right.
- I just believe--
- 'Cause it will, right?
You can accept it--
- You can go with
it or it leaves you.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- And I don't want to sound
like the grouchy old rapper.
- Right. In my day.
- Yeah, in my day was like this.
We just gotta embrace the youth.
You know?
- You ready to
answer some questions?
- Absolutely.
- India?
- Ready.
- You ready to ask some questions?
- I am.
- India, did you think that you
have a day in your career where
you were going to
ask Fat Joe questions?
Was this something that when you
thought as a little girl growing
up in San Francisco.
- No.
- Yeah. Let's fire away.
- Cool.
First one's from Clayton.
- Oh video. Clayton. Alright.
- Hey Fat Joe,
welcome to the show.
The question I have is you
did that song with Ashanti
a while ago. I think it's
called "What's Love".
How do artists ever hook up and
how do they get to collaborate
with each other?
Is there somebody like producers
that brings that or agent,
how does that happen?
- How do collabo's happen?
Take it away.
- A lot of times with me when
I make music I hear a certain
artist on it and I reach out
and I hope they want to
work with me.
- Like flat-out?
You got it in your head and
you're like this would be
perfect for this person?
- Let's skip that.
- Go ahead.
- Let's just say Cool &amp; Dre,
Scott Storch may get it popping
and I immediately
heard Nelly on there.
So we reached out and Cool &amp; Dre
wrote the hook and I reached out
to Nelly and I was like,
"Nelly, do you want to do
this hook over for me,"
and he said yes.
We heard him on the song.
"Make It Rain" I wrote the hook
to "Make It Rain" and I heard
Lil Wayne on it because it was a
South song and I was like,
"Yo, Wayne can you do this
over," he did it.
You hear certain artist that you
want to collaborate with on the
songs and you hope sometimes.
- Have you ever been devastated
when you've really wanted it?
- Not devastated but I've been
chasing Future on this album and
he's been acting
real Hollywood with me.
Acting like he don't
want to do this song.
- Uh-huh.
- Got to be honest with you.
- Playing hard to get you think?
- Yeah, hard to get
sometimes it's like that.
You know?
- Of course.
Let me play it in for
everybody who's watching.
Same thing in business, a lot of
people always ask me how do you
get an angel deals when you
invest in the people when you
are doing these things?
It comes in all forms.
Sometimes it comes to you,
sometimes reach out but I love,
I was curious how you
were going to answer it.
I think sometimes people try to
big up too much and I have too
much pride and they don't want
to reach out. When you want
something you have to
go out and grab it.
I love instead of you saying oh
sometimes it comes to me or this
and that you said look I hear
somebody I wanted,
I'll reach out.
Sometimes they say yes,
sometimes they say no.
Way too many people
watching right now, you know how
successful this
man is in his genre?
You know how many of you are
too proud to reach out to do
something with somebody and you
haven't made shit happen yet.
- Nah, that's not how it works.
- No, it is not.
- That's not how it works.
- I think one thing and I'll use
this moment I've been wanting to
say this to really win you
have to equally pull
at ego and humility.
What do you think?
- What I have done,
what I've done
the new Fat Joe--
- And when did the new Fat
Joe come out in your world?
- Maybe this year.
- Okay.
- Let's just say
it all the way up.
- Okay. Yep.
- I've had riffs and not
everything was so good between
me and Jay-Z in the past.
- [Gary] Yep. Yep.
- I reached out to him--
- [Gary] Be the bigger man.
- Yes and collaborated
and we did the remix.
- [Gary] That was big
news in that world.
That was big news.
- I did not see eye to
eye with Daddy Yankee.
I got him on the Spanish remix.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- Me and 50 Cent made peace
and now we performed together not
too long ago.
I laid down.
- [Gary] Are you enjoying this?
- I'm enjoying it because you
eliminate all the barriers.
- That's right.
- You know what I'm saying?
All the enemies and
all the people--
- When did this happen?
January 1 thing for you?
Was it a long time?
- It wasn't January 1.
It was just me.
I tried all the wars--
- Right.
- And then I just said to
myself, you know what I'm going
to eliminate all obstacles.
And I'm going to try to say
put all ego and pride aside
and let me just try
the non-ego route.
Let me try working with
everybody and see how this
workin' and so far we're
platinum on the single,
go on to double platinum,
tours opening up--
- Go figure.
Go figure.
Go with positivity
and imagine that.
- It's a magical miracle
pill that seems to be working.
- Yeah, it happens.
I'm glad you went there.
It's been a theme of mine
over my whole life but
I've been really...
With all the shit that's
going on in the world,
if you can't go half glass full.
If you can't be the person of
change and drive positivity and
optimism I just
think it is a mistake.
India.
- Mhmmm.
- [India] This is from Craig.
- Craig.
- [Voiceover] Craig asked,
"What do you think people like
"Chance the Rapper releasing a
lot of his music for free as a
"marketing strategy?"
- What do you think Chance the
Rapper, people like
Chance the Rapper, what do you
think about Chance's music?
- I love Chance the Rapper.
- I'm obsessed.
(mumbled singing)
What do you think about
people like Chance
and others that are putting
out a lot of mixtapes, a lot of
product for free as a
marketing play or
whatever the strategy may be?
- I love it. I love it.
I think you keep the relevancy
and you keep the fans engaged.
I love it.
I think it's a hustle.
It shows that you dedicated to
the art and at the end of the
day the art wasn't meant
to be materialism and
everything is a dollar.
It's about giving back
to your fans anyway.
- I think the one thing that a
lot of you are watching know is
I don't have the $500
e-books and the $7,000 courses.
I do the shows for free.
I pump out content
at scale for free.
Thousands of you email me
every single month,
"You should charge for this.
"This is better than the
shit I'm paying more for."
It plays into that same thesis
which is yes but that's why so
many more of you follow me.
- You get engaged. Yes.
- Of course.
Either you're running a marathon
or you're running a sprint.
Figure out what you are doing.
- Exactly.
- India.
- [India] Next one from OTFN.
- [Voiceover] OTWHouston asked,
"What is the most important or
"best aspect of a live
music event or experience?"
- I can't answer that.
- The most important aspect?
- This is you.
- Just getting the
people and getting engaged.
See I try to die every
time I'm on the stage.
- Die?
- Die. Like physically--
- You go so hard
that just might go.
- I try to die.
- I like that.
- I would love to die on stage.
- Seriously, right?
- Seriously.
- I get it.
- What happens is--
- You look good these days.
- Thanks so much.
- You're probably less likely
to do than I'm back in a day.
- I'm trying.
I've been trying.
- You're looking good, man.
- I've been trying
to workout every day.
- Back in the day you might
have been able to pull that off.
Looking good though now.
- I know, I know, I know.
What happens is
I've analyzed this
so hard to where
times are hard and everybody
doesn't have money like that.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- And everybody doesn't
give money the same way.
I've analyzed it to where people
buy tickets to go to shows to
where every single dollar
tells a different story.
So everybody who's in
this audience had to
do a different thing.
Work harder, work extra
hours, borrow some money,
sell something that they really
loved to see their
favorite rapper.
- [Gary] Just to see that show.
- Do whatever.
So every ticket tells a
different story so it's my
obligation that if they
went through their,
through all these
changes to see me being their
favorite rapper then I have to
give them my all in the show.
- [Gary] I love that.
This is now me jumping in.
What is your favorite, what
are your some of your favorite
venues to perform in?
Do you have a
favorite venue or two?
I saw you at Citi Field
the other day.
- My favorite show I've ever
done in my life was last night.
- Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Your favorite show--
- I've ever done in my life.
My best moment in my
career was last night.
- Well I worked until two in the
morning and I've been up since
five working so I
need to hear the story.
- So what happened was yesterday
I did Summer Stage in
Katonah Park in the Bronx.
- Hmmm.
- It's the park I grew up in.
It's like three blocks
away from my neighborhood.
My grandmother grew up
three blocks in that direction.
I grew up three
blocks in this direction.
It's never seen
no shit like this.
So it's usually
500 people at that.
There was literally
20,000 people there and 5,000.
- [Gary] You saw people.
- No, I've seen
everybody's mother.
Everybody I went to school with.
- You saw people that
you hadn't seen in years.
- It looked like
Summer Jam, man.
It looked like Summer Jam in the
middle of the park I grew up in.
I have a scar where I fell in
the pool where I have stitches
my father sold Icees
and beef patties in the
summer in this park.
- [Gary] It was a coming home.
- Oh my God.
I almost cried on stage.
- [Gary] You never
performed there before?
- It was the craziest shit
I've ever seen in my life.
- [Gary] Good for you, man.
Congratulations.
- So when I got on stage it was
overwhelming when I looked out
it just looked like Yankee
Stadium and it was my whole
neighborhood and
I was like, "Oh shit."
And so many years I've been
fighting for the Bronx and
talking about
yo I'm from the Bronx.
I'm representing the Bronx.
And when I see they all came
out they were like, "Yeah, bro."
- That's nice, man.
- Welcome home.
- Good for you man.
- It was the biggest
moment for me in my life.
- Congratulations.
That's nice.
- Thank you.
- [India] That was awesome.
- It is awesome.
- [India] Martin.
- Martin.
- Hey guys, what's up?
With who do you really want
to work with before you die?
Keep up the good work.
- I'll go first.
I want to for work
with Vince McMahon.
- [Man] Oh WWF?
- Yes, sir.
- WWE.
- And I'll tell you why.
WWE now but we're old school.
WWF.
Yeah, I'm Macho
Man Randy Savage.
- Randy.
- For me, I love storytelling
and I love people
that loved characters.
What I get excited about is
Walt Disney, Vince McMahon,
people that create
characters and IP.
Intellectual property so for
me Vince is intriguing to me
because I'm 40 I grew up in that
era of the golden era of that
Hulkamania, Macho
madness and so--
- The Hulkster's my man.
- Yeah, Hulk was in
here the other day.
It was a lot of fun.
For me it's Vince McMahon.
You?
- Shit. What was the question
- Who do you--
- 'cause he got me fucked up.
I was in Gary's world right now.
(laughter)
What was the question again?
- [India] Person you want
to work with before you die?
- Person I want to
work with before I die.
I don't know I think
I would want to do
a movie with Will Smith.
Something like that.
- Nice answer.
- Will Smith--
- Did you Will, I mean you
were around back then so--
- Nah, man.
- Was he a little earlier?
- Nah, he was earlier than me
and I met Will maybe once or
twice but I mean like if there's
anybody I want to make a movie
with it's Will Smith.
- Joe, have you thought about
doing collaborations on
cross genre music?
Have you ever heard
a country singer or?
- That's what I want to
work with, country music.
- Really?
- Yeah, that's who
I want to work with.
- I actually, this is me from
afar, as a fan, just thinking
about it I have a funny feeling
that you would do quite well in
collaborations in
different genres.
- It's true and that's
where I'm looking towards.
Right now country music.
- Andy, I'm not just predicting
social media shit, Andy.
I predict music shit.
- No, it's the fucking truth.
(laughter)
It's the truth--
- I love it.
- I'm looking towards country.
I don't know shit about country
but I fucking love that
their fans are loyal.
- [Gary] Loyal.
- I love that the fans are
fucking loyal and I love they're
like hip hop.
They're just
telling it their own way.
- [Gary] 100%.
- And they're coming
from the ground up.
I fucking love it.
- [Gary] 100%.
You imagine Fat Joe and TSwift?
That would be the summer anthem.
- Some people get a beat
up at country shit too.
I seen Kenny Chesney's shit.
- There's thugs everywhere.
- We got thugs everywhere.
(laughter)
- What do we got one more?
- [India] That's it actually.
- That's it?
- [India] Yeah. You can
ask a question yourself.
- That's true, okay.
Joe, where are you
at with social media?
- Social media, at first
I was anti-social media.
- Right.
By the way, real quick I want to
teach a lot people here because
a lot of youngsters.
When social media came up,
when I jumped on it
'06, '07, '08, '09--
- Wow.
- when people were
famous back then it was
just a small little thing.
It was a small platform--
- We were more like private.
We didn't want people
to know our business.
- Because the media was already
writing stuff they didn't want
anyways so why do I
need more of this?
They didn't understand it
and things of that nature.
- I started very, very late.
With me, put it like this,
I had a BlackBerry last year.
BlackBerry doesn't even have
Instagram and social media so
what happened was--
- [Gary] How was the
conversion to a smart phone?
Did you like it?
- It was very great.
(laughter)
When I finally got me a fucking
iPhone and I was like,
"Where the fuck it's
been all my life?"
- Were you just
holding out on principle?
You made a lot,
wait a minute, real quick,
you made a lot of changes.
- A lot of changes.
- Technology, yeah
I know, I'm watching.
Isn't it great?
- Fucking phenomenal.
- You love 2016.
- Yeah, I love 2016
and now I run my
own social media,
my own Facebook, my own
Twitter, my own Instagram.
I'm having fun doing this shit.
- What about Snapchat?
- Snap too.
I fucking love it all.
- When Khaled started blowing up
in November, December, January
were you talking to him
about it, did you see it?
- He came from a real place.
- I know it did.
What happened with Khaled was
and this can be breaking news
to the world--
- Okay, I like breaking news.
- What happened with
Khaled was Khaled was at a
very low point in his life.
He had an album come out
that didn't do too well.
- That's right.
- He had some very close
friends that started to
turn their back on him.
And he found himself in his
home on talking to the lion and
talking on the kayak and the
rafe talking and he was just
discovered this Snap thing.
So he just started talking and
being on board and talking to
the people and the next thing
you know people discovered what
I discovered 10, 15 years before
that he's the most amazing
mother fucker on Earth and now
he turned in to Beatlemania.
- [Gary] It's insanity.
- So that's how we all, you
know, America got to discover
the real DJ Khaled.
- [Gary] I love it.
Amazing stuff.
- It's amazing because other
than that, in other words,
you had to go through adversity.
You have to fall to get up.
- [Gary] And he really got up.
- Oh shit.
- [Gary] And he's taking
Arianna Huff, all the way up.
- He's all the way up.
- [Gary] All the way up.
- I mean I don't know what, he
might be selling dog food next.
- He's selling everything.
Everybody wants him.
- Milk.
- His name is brought up in all
three of these floor every day
with every brand in the world.
- Incredible.
- Unbelievable.
Joe you get to ask the
question of the day.
Every guest that comes on gets
to ask all these entrepreneurs,
business people, you know,
motivated individuals
any question.
Hundreds of answers on Facebook
and YouTube, any question
you want to know
from the masses.
- My question is what are we
going to do about these police
killing these people in America
and how can we change it?
Because my fans and
my followers are
asking me this and
I'm not God.
I'm not Jesus Christ.
I can't, I don't
have the answers. Right?
So maybe you guys can give me
the smartest answers in the
world because what are we
going to do because I feel like
America is going 100 steps back.
And it's very, it's like all of
us who took 100 steps forward
and came together
as one big race.
In this room alone we have so
much diversity and we all look
to each other as one big happy
family, there's a group of us
out there that's
trying to erase that.
And split us up.
And I'm tired of
seeing men get killed
by people power tripping
and there nothing
I can do about it.
- Yep.
- And it's getting
really, really, really,
really scary out there.
I love my country--
- Yep.
- and I don't have the answers.
- Great.
Team let's round up five or
seven of the best ones and get
it over to him as well.
To make sure he sees them.
Joe, this is a real honor for me
and to have on the show, my man.
- Thank you, Gary.
Nothing but love.
- I wish you continued success.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.